m1 ultra yes it's here it is finally
here the moment that we have been
waiting for the chip is i cannot believe
that apple just revealed it and it is
absolutely insane and let me tell you
it's killing intel alder lake and i'm
gonna get into that in this video going
into a deep dive into this new m1 ultra
chip now i know i got the name wrong i
thought it was gonna be the m1 max duo
but ultra is just killer killing until
alder lake and i'm so happy that i was
one of the first people out there on
youtube who put out a story on this new
chip way back last year when i released
this video showing off this new duo chip
which is basically two m1 maxes put
together and then back on december 2nd
somebody leaked a real photo of the m1
max die and i noticed something on the
die that apple kept a secret from
everyone the entire time yes there was a
secret die to die interconnect that
fully supported my theory on apple
putting two of these dyes together and
that was based on mark german's leak of
a future apple silicon chip coming with
exactly two times more cpu and gpu cores
and while i thought it was going into
the imac pro first that unfortunately
didn't happen and it looks like apple is
doing everything they can to get people
to buy the expensive brand new mac
studio instead of an imac and we know
that for sure because they completely
discontinued the 27-inch intel imac and
they still didn't release the redesigned
apple silicon mac mini which was
supposed to replace the intel mac mini
which is still there on apple's website
and apple is absolutely genius because
this move that they just did with their
mac studio caused us to literally order
three of them yes
max ordered three max studio models for
over 17 thousand dollars total so that
we can compare the different chip
options to show you which upgrades are
worth it and which are not so if you're
excited to see that go ahead and
subscribe right now so you don't miss
out on those comparison videos and by
the way this video is going to be fully
dedicated to going deep into the m1
ultra chip architecture and explaining
things that apple didn't mention at the
event and we're going to have another
video coming soon dedicated to the mac
studio so stay tuned for that and now
with that said let's dig deep into the
m1 ultra chip first off this chip is
absolutely
massive it's going to be so long that
it'll essentially stretch across the
entire max studio logic board which is
actually a very good thing for cooling
performance and like i said before apple
is using an interconnect section on the
bottom of each m1 max die to connect
both dyes into one and the best part of
all is that apple did all of the
groundwork to make it behave like a
single die chip and this is extremely
important because it means that
developers don't have to do any work at
all to take full advantage of the m1
ultra unlike many of the dual xeon intel
chips out there that have issues with
software support where some programs
aren't able to take full advantage of
those dual cpu systems but that will not
be an issue at all with the m1 ultra and
we know that for sure because apple says
that the interposer between both dies
has 2.5 terabytes per second of
bandwidth thanks to the ultra fusion
fabric which is absolutely mind-blowing
and it basically ensures that you won't
have any bottlenecks between the dies
they'll basically run at full
performance as long as the cooling
system can keep up and we basically know
that for sure because apple is rating it
at up to 800 gigabytes per second dram
bandwidth which is exactly two times
more than the m1 max which means that
apple isn't expecting any bottlenecks at
all even with the massive up to 128 gigs
of unified memory being shared between
the interposer with both dies thanks to
the ultra fusion fabric this is a huge
deal because this means that apps that
require a ton of vram like 3d video
rendering will have up to 128 gigs of
vram which is literally the most you can
get in any computer ever made especially
compared to only 24 gigabytes on
nvidia's new high-end rtx 30 90 gpu but
now in terms of the actual performance
this new m1 ultra has a massive
114 billion transistors with 16 high
performance cores and four efficiency
cores as well as up to a crazy 64
gpu cores that will give you up to 21 t
flops of performance and if you're
wondering how that compares to other
systems i'll get into that in just a
moment but the huge point i want to make
to you guys is that it's not just the
performance that's going to be doubled
compared to the m1 max but all of the
little chips within the dies are doubled
as well which means that you get a 32
core neural engine you get double the
slc cache you get four amx
multiplication cores you get a total of
eight thunderbolt 4 controllers you get
two secure enclaves for automatic
hardware encryption and of course the
biggest deal of all is that you get a
total of two video decode engines for
video and code engines and four sets of
prores encode slash decode engines and
this right here is going to be a massive
deal because right now with a lot of the
best nvidia gpus like the rtx 3090 the
high raw power is limited by the slow
end code and decode engines meaning that
it doesn't really help you export videos
much faster than other lower end gpus
but with the m1 ultra you're literally
getting the world's fastest video
editing performance on any consumer
computer or gpu we're talking support
for 18 streams of 8k prores video
playback which is basically overkill for
99 of the people out there and if you're
wondering how it's going to compare to
other systems let's jump right into that
as usual apple showed off some pretty
vague charts comparing the m1 ultra to a
16 core pc desktop chip claiming that
it's 90 faster while using 100 watts
less power but if you go into the
footnotes at the bottom of apple's m1
ultra page you'll see that apple was
actually comparing it to the brand new
i9 12 900k alder lake chip which is
absolutely mind-blowing and making it
even better i mean this is crazy they
said that it's 60 faster than the best
of the best 28 core xeon cpu in the
current mac pro so we know we're really
getting that much performance out of a
60 watt chip yes only 60 watts for the
cpu but what you need to realize is that
the unified memory architecture alone
will allow this m1 ultra chip to shine
in real world programs compared to
traditional x86 intel chips that have
more latency because of the use of
traditional ram to communicate to other
parts of the system like the gpu and
speaking of the graphics apple claims
that the 64 core gpu version of the m1
ultra is faster than nvidia's top of the
line rtx 30 90 gpu within a pc that also
has the 12900k alder lake chip
and it's doing it while using a massive
200 watts of power less this is
absolutely mind-blowing because i
expected the m1 max quadro
die chip to compete with the 3090 not
this dual m1 ultra champ so the craziest
thing of all is that this new chip
should outperform apple's top of the
line intel mac pro and basically every
real world task even though it's only
five thousand dollars for the top spec
m1 ultra chip compared to tens of
thousands of dollars for an intel mac
pro with those crazy chips so with that
said it's safe to say that intel's new
alder lake chips are basically getting
destroyed at this point especially since
the new m1 ultra sips power and has
unprecedented levels of unified memory
that can also be used as vram and i'm so
happy that we're finally going to be
getting our hands on it here in the next
10 days so if you want to watch our
in-depth comparison videos with all
three of our max studios then click that
circle above right there to subscribe
for those videos coming up soon and
definitely check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in tomorrow's video